Matt we got some breaking news we do
glad Amir Putin is saying that the loss
of this Russian warplane today was due
to back stabbing he says that Russia has
an agreement with the u.s. as far as the
safety of planes over Syria and that
Turkey is part of that agreement so he's
very angry about this saying that the
plane was a kilometer away from the
Turkish border when it was shot it
landed four kilometers away from the
Turkish border when it was downed he
says this will have serious consequences
for Russia's relationship with Turkey
and that he's going to do something in
order to show them that he takes this
very seriously so it'll it'll have
serious consequences again for the ties
ties of Turkey I want to make clear that
the Turkish government has supported
Turkmen rebels in Syria against Bashar
al-assad's government now Russia of
course not only supports Bashar
al-assad's government but supplies them
with su-24 planes so Syrians are flying
these jets as well as Russians flying
these jets and that could make for
misunderstanding in Turkey all right and
simply saying we won't tolerate this
what do you make of this Marty still we
would like to know did he say anything
about the fate of the pilots I guess he
did not I think a lot will be determined
on where they are and whether they get
back quickly but it doesn't sound like
he's walking it back down no no no but
this is not taken oh he can't turn out
of the situation you can't be worried
that his natural impulse is always to go
so strong it's heavy so aggressive given
the climate that we're in that is not
exactly the kind of statement that's
going to be and you sort of do wonder
what happened at the moment that the
Turkish pilots were going back to
headquarters and saying should we go or
not and somebody decided to say yes
interesting there we go who says Russian
warplane in no way threatened Turkey he
says loss of Russian warplane today due
to back stabbing which we covered the
incident serious consequences for
Turkey's ties we really have to break
down what this means from a business
perspective in terms of being these
images were showing right
now of the jet being shot down I mean
these are big big trading partners so
what does this mean for a country as
small as Turkey you've got to think
their exports to a place as big as
Russia this could be a massive hit to
their economy and Turkey has not been
having an easy time recently with its
economy and I think that's exactly mean
the trading partner and the sinners use
their and sort of in all sorts of
markets go that it's one of their main
trading partners and I think you'll see
him come down heavy I think you'll see
him come down hard
I think the repercussions of this could
be quite lasting for Turkey at least
over the next you know several months
and it's just it's exactly the wrong
time how does she even been three weeks
ago and this had happened we would have
seen I think much less global attention
but now the eyes the world are on this
so Turkey being at odds with Russia what
is that do for Turkey and the rest of
the world from a tourism and travel
standpoint are people from the rest of
the world going to want to go to Turkey
a country that is potentially at odds
with Vladimir Putin well it depends on
the Putin response if he decides to do
something particularly aggressive and
destabilize the area even more than it
is now it will have a very chilling
effect on tourism and we could only hope
that that doesn't happen right but you
have to bear in mind Turkey is part of
NATO mm-hmm
and you know you have to be both sides
would be very careful now about
escalating this if I could get in a
situation you don't want to be in really
fast and you also have to bear in mind
though you have no idea what Vladimir
Putin could do or say at any time the
fact that someone's a member of NATO
that's not something Vladimir Putin
necessarily cares about